اهلا بكم في موجز الاخبار من قناه الجزيره
اعلنت السعوديه والولايات المتحده ان
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع وقع
اتفاقا قصيره المدى للقتال في السودان
مصحوبا بترتيبات انسانيه وقال بيان سعودي
امريكي مشترك ان وقف القتال يدخل حيز
التنفيذ بعد 48 ساعه من توقيع الاتفاق
ويسري لمده سبعه ايام ويمكن تمديده
بموافقه طرفين هذا واكد البيان ان اليه
مراقبه وقف القتال ستكون مدعومه من
الولايات المتحده والسعوديه
من جهاتها قالت الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
الوزيره اتصل بقائد الجيش السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان وناقشها المحادثات الجاريه
في جثه وافاد البيان بان بلينكن جدد
ادانته لاعمال العنف التي ارتكبتها القوات
المسلحه وقوه الدعم السريعه وبانه اكد
للبرهان ان التوصل لاتفاق في السعوديه
سيسمح بتقديم المساعدات الانسانيه
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه السيطره
الكامله على مدينه باخم الواقعه الشمال
مقاطعه دونيتسكا وكان رئيس شركه فاغنر
الروسيه اعلن هو ايضا سيطره قوته على كامل
مدينه باخمت في شرق اوكرانيا
في المقابل قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
ان القتال في باخمه مستمر وكان المتحدث
باسم القوات الاوكرانيه في الجبهه الشرقيه
اكد ان القوات بلاده ما زالت تقاتل في
ضخمه
اعلن الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن حزمه
مساعدات امريكيه جديده لاوكرانيا تشمل
اسلحه وذخائر ومدرعات من جانبه قال رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني ان المقرر ان يبدا
تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين هذا الصيف هذا
وكان قاده مجموعه السبع المجتمعون في
مدينه هيروشيما اليابانيه قد تعهدوا
بمواصله محاسبه روسيا ومن يدعمها في حربها
على اوكرانيا وجدد القاده في البيان
الختمي التزامهم بدعم اوكرانيا مهما تطلب
احلال السلام الشامل من وقت كما حذر الصين
من مواقف احاديه ودعوها الى الضغط على
روسيا بشان الحرب في اوكرانيا
هذا واتهم وزير الخارجيه الروسي السرجي
دول الغربيه بمحاوله هزيمه بلاده والقضاء
عليها كمنافس جيوسياسي حسب وصفه واضاف ان
الغرب حدد مهمته بالقضاء على روسيا وهو ما
تمثل في القرارات التي اتخذت في هيروشيما
والتي تهدف الى الردع المزدوج لروسيا
والصين بحسب قوله
من جهتها انتقدت الخارجيه الصينيه عدم
تطرق مجموعه السبع لمعارضه استقلال تايوان
وقالت في بياننا التواطؤ مع القوى المؤيده
للاستقلال يؤثر على استقرار مضيق تايوان
ووصف البيان ذلك بانه عرقل للسلام وتقويد
للاستقرار الاقليمي وتجاهل لما خاوي في
اللقاء
[موسيقى]